Vladimir Poutine
contestée par une partie de son peuple
et de plus en plus isolé sur la scène
internationale
une mauvaise passe symbolisée par ses
nouvelles manifestations aujourd'hui à
Moscou enfin plus tôt par ces centaines
d'interpellations
cette femme est arrêtée dès qu'elle
scande son slogan contre la mobilisation
des réservistes en fait pas de
rassemblement possible pour ces russes
qui avaient donné la consigne de
s'habiller en noir
Vladimir Poutine obligé donc
d'intensifier la répression notamment
contre ceux qui refusent de se battre
il signe aujourd'hui un amendement
prévoyant 10 ans de prison pour les
militaires qui désertent mais aussi pour
ceux qui fuient alors qu'ils ont été
convoqués aujourd'hui
2300 voitures patientes à ce poste
frontière avec la Géorgie à bord des
Russes qui refusent d'aller au combat en
Ukraine
je n'aime pas ce que font nos autorités
en Ukraine
j'ai de la pitié pour mes frères
Ukrainiens je déteste ce qui se passe en
Ukraine
cette vidéo amateur montre des Russes
rassemblés dans des bus pour aller au
front les hommes très récalcitrants
protestent en essayant d'obliger les
policiers à embarquer eux aussi vers la
guerre
Vladimir Poutine confronté aussi à
l'incompétence de certains de ces
généraux
Dimitri Boulgakov par exemple ce haut
gradé chargé de la logistique de l'armée
russe a été limogé aujourd'hui
remplacé par cette autre général induire
visé par des sanctions occidentales pour
son rôle dans le siège de Marion Paul
son nouveau défi organisationnel
convoqué des milliers de réservistes les
équiper les former au plus vite et les
acheminer vers le front